hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today's topic is the chavacano language
a Spanish Creole in fact the only
spanish-based creole language in asia
the name of the language comes from the
spanish word chavacano meaning vulgar or
in poor taste
that's because chavacano was originally
considered incorrect or corrupted
spanish chavacano is spoken in the
Philippines and is a direct result of
the Philippines history as a Spanish
colony it's not spoken by the majority
of Filipinos but by a minority living in
specific areas it's spoken in different
varieties in Cavite a province just
south of Metro Manila in Cotabato on the
island of Mindanao Basilan island to the
south of Mindanao and it's spoken by the
largest number of speakers in Zamboanga
especially Zamboanga City on Mindanao
it's notoriously difficult to find
consistent statistics about the number
of chavacano speakers but according to
the United Nations statistics division
in 2005 there were four hundred and
thirty-one thousand native speakers
including around three hundred and
eleven thousand in Zamboanga but those
numbers underestimate the number of
people who speak chavacano Zamboanga
City a city with over a million people
is a very diverse place with migrants
from all over the Philippines and
chavacano serves as the most common
lingua franca so hundreds of thousands
more people speak it as a second or
third language so what is it exactly is
it Spanish well not exactly
it's a spanish-based creole meaning that
Spanish is the LexA fire language the
language that supplied most of the
vocabulary while the grammar is largely
based on Filipino languages like the
Scientology and Heilig I know the
Spanish colonial period in the
Philippines began in 1521 and beginning
in 1565 the Philippine Islands began to
be administered from the Viceroyalty of
New Spain which was based in Mexico City
this continued until Mexico's
independence in 1821 after which the
Philippines were administered directly
by Spain but for those 256 years
Philippines had significant interaction
with New Spain and its people during
this time the Philippines and New Spain
were connected by the galleon trade
large trading ship voyages that made the
journey between Manila and Acapulco once
or twice a year
this brought Filipinos in contact with
spanish-speaking workers from New Spain
while soldiers and settlers from Spain
were present soldiers and settlers from
New Spain also arrived in significant
numbers one place where many newcomers
settled was in Zamboanga which the
Spanish seized in 1635 in an attempt to
stop attacks by Moro pirates they
established a fortress called
at A&F where'sa de san jose royal fort
of st. joseph the population of this
fort had a direct impact on the
development of the chavacano spoken in
Zamboanga there were Visayan warriors
from Cebu and other areas Spanish
soldiers including those from Spain
Mexico as well as Peru and Jesuit
priests who served as Spanish Visayan
translators and might have taught the
others how to communicate resulting in a
pidgin language that would become the
chavacano creole this fort was
eventually abandoned but some of the
population remained and continued to
interact with locals while the Jesuit
priests continued their conversion
efforts this both spread chavacano and
brought additional influences to the
language making it a little more
Filipino and a little less Spanish this
is the kind of contact that resulted in
the creation of other forms of chavacano
as well but the exact influences were
somewhat different for example the
chavacano spoken and coveted has more
Castilian Spanish influence and less
Mexican Spanish influence and has more
Tagalog influence rather than recited
now let's look at some features of
chavacano and see how it differs from
Spanish I'm focusing mainly on Zamboanga
newel the chavacano Creole spoken in
Zamboanga we'll start by focusing on the
syntax and I'll introduce additional
elements as we go while Spanish is
generally SVO chavacano is generally VSO
like Tagalog or Visayan here's the
sentence meaning the man looked at Jose
in Spanish el hombre Mito Jose and in
chavacano
yo mira el hombre con Jose in Spanish
the subject el hombre comes first but in
chavacano it comes after the verb there
are some other important things we can
notice about this sentence the verb
middle from me rod
means look in Spanish while in chavacano
it means both look and see so depending
on the intended meaning the Spanish
translation might be illuminate be a
HOSA using a different verb to mean see
also notice that the verb forms are
slightly different the Spanish verb is
conjugated for the third person singular
conjugation in the preterite or passed
historic tense but chavacano verbs are
not conjugated at all the verb Mira will
be the same for any subject the only
thing that can change is this extra
little piece right here which is a pre
verb that shows tents yaw indicates past
top indicates present and eye indicates
future these are not always used but can
be used for clarity and for emphasis
also notice that chavacano uses cone
instead of a cone comes from the Spanish
word cone meaning with but in chavacano
it's used as the object or accusative
marker so already we can see a number of
differences between Spanish and
chavacano another example here's a
sentence meaning you teach children you
being the plural form in Spanish ustedes
encinia and English and in chavacano the
encino stayed Islamic about that again
in Spanish the subject comes first in in
chavacano it comes after the verb and
you'll notice the present tense pre verb
top before the verb na is allocative
particle or preposition which shows
direction or location
apparently it comes from asturian and
note the difference in vocabulary for
the words meaning children in chavacano
you'll see the phrase mana bata maja is
a plural marker found in Tagalog Visayan
and Hiligaynon in chavacano this is
sometimes used as the plural marker and
the Spanish plural form with S or ES is
sometimes used another example here's a
sentence meaning I love you in Spanish
yo te amo or te amo
and a chavacano a Mayo contigo or mayo
bond eagle this time the Spanish
sentence is sov not SVO because when the
object is a pronoun it usually comes
before the verb but in Spanish the
subject pronoun can be dropped because
the person and number are clear from the
conjugation of the verb in chavacano
however
verbs
not conjugated so the subject pronoun is
necessary and notice that the prover
is optional earlier we saw that cone
meaning with in Spanish is used as the
object marker in chavacano here Contego
which means with you in spanish is used
as the object pronoun all of the subject
pronouns of Spanish origin have an
object pronoun equivalent like this that
begins with cone there are other subject
pronouns of Filipino origin and their
corresponding object pronouns are also a
Filipino origin some pronouns might come
from Filipino languages because they
communicate something that the Spanish
pronouns couldn't communicate notice for
example the first person plural pronouns
Khmer and Gita which come from Visayan
some Austronesian languages including
some languages of the Philippines
distinguished between the first person
plural inclusive of the listener and
exclusive of the listener another
example here's a sentence meaning this
is Pablo in Spanish este es Pablo and in
chavacano see Pablo stay again in
Spanish the subject comes first
it's the demonstrative pronoun este in
chavacano it comes after the predicate
and you can see that the pronoun is
abbreviated but it's not always so
there's actually no verb in this
sentence because chavacano has no copula
so the word order is really predicate
subject the word see is a subject marker
for personal names which is also found
in Tagalog Visayan and Hiligaynon in
spanish demonstrative pronouns have
gender but chavacano has no grammatical
gender so for a female name in Spanish
it would be like this
esta is Trisha with a change in the
pronoun while in chavacano it would be
this situation este with no change in
the pronoun another element of the word
order that is different is that
adjectives come before nouns in
chavacano not after in Spanish we have
aa deliberative meaning free time and a
chavacano we have libre hora another
sentence here's a sentence meaning I
love their house in Spanish yo amo su
casa mo Tsukasa and in chavacano mayor
de la casa again notice that in the
Spanish sentence you can drop the
subject
but in chavacano you can't the third
in plural possessive pronoun in
chavacano is deala the possessive
pronouns typically consist of D prefixed
to the beginning of the Spanish subject
pronouns or to filipino clinic pronouns
another sentence here's a sentence
meaning wanna or Jane bought a second
dog in Spanish wanna accomplish mundo
better and in chavacano comprar one
Godot sparrow again we see the SVO
versus VSO we see the subject marker C
and a pre verb in chavacano and we see
the word for dog there's one new thing
to notice here the ordinal number in
Spanish is Segundo but in chavacano it's
Iike DOS the cardinal numbers of
chavacano like those are all basically
the same as in Spanish but with slightly
different spelling but while Spanish has
different forms for ordinal numbers
chavacano prefixes Iike two cardinal
numbers notice that the Spanish ordinal
number primero is used and other Spanish
ones can be used in place of the
chavacano forms too Segundo for example
now let's look at a couple more
sentences and see what we find
here's a sentence meaning the book will
be published in five languages in
Spanish and Libre said a publicado and
think I do mas word-for-word it's the
book will be published in five languages
and in chavacano le bromance Elena sing
: go ahead word-for-word it's the book
verbal prefix come out in five language
in this sentence we see that the subject
comes first in both sentences in
chavacano SVO word order is possible for
example it's often found in news stories
that are translated from Spanish media
keeping the text as similar to the
Spanish version as possible another
thing is that in chavacano there's no
passive form so passive meaning is
understood from context or the action
can be paraphrased in Spanish the
sentence is explicitly future but the
chavacano sentence doesn't have the
future pre verb I it can have it but
here it doesn't we see here that the
verb is preceded by Mon Mon is a prefix
that makes a verb distributive meaning
that the action is performed by several
subjects or on several objects
separately here the book will be
released
five different times in five different
versions so Mun is used to show the
distribution of the action among the
different releases of the book Mun is
also a prefix that can be attached to
nouns and English loanwords to turn them
into chavacano verbs Hmong translate Mon
picnic Mon reply etc there's a similar
prefix mug in Tagalog and Visayan and
noticed that the word for languages in
Spanish is idiomas while in chavacano
it's lenguaje in chavacano and other
languages of the philippines lenguaje is
used to refer to languages that are
spoken by communities of people while in
spanish language a refers more to the
general concept of language so to refer
to a specific human language in spanish
idioma is the typical word and one last
sentence this sentence means they left
without paying for the drink
in Spanish say foreign chimp at la Vida
word-for-word it's reflexive particle
they went without pay the drink in
chavacano es le salon way back opponent
Hamada word for word it's past tense pre
verb leave they without pay object
marker definite article alcoholic drink
this last sentence is fairly different
from its Spanish equivalent first notice
that the verbs are different in Spanish
we see the reflexive form of the verb
eared meaning to go the reflexive form
is used to mean leave chavacano doesn't
have this construction so another verb
is used instead it's a derivative of the
Spanish word salir meaning to go out
Cielo is the third-person plural subject
pronoun which comes from Tagalog and
Visayan in Y is a negative pre verb for
the past tense
Cannell is a combination of cone the
object marker plus L the definite
article finally we have the word tamada
which means alcoholic drink in chavacano
while in Spanish it's baby de chavacano
also has a similar word baby but that is
a general word for a drink not
specifically an alcoholic drink before I
mentioned that chavacano was influenced
by Mexican Spanish there was undoubtedly
some influence on the pronunciation of
chavacano
in chavacano also contains some
vocabulary that clearly came from
Mexican Spanish for example
meaning grass this is originally a word
from Nahuatl an indigenous language of
Mexico
it entered Mexican Spanish as a loanword
and then entered chavacano via Mexican
Spanish these words are also from
Nahuatl shangay meaning market which
comes from yungay chongo meaning monkey
from Django and camote meaning sweet
potato there are other words and
expressions that don't come from Nahuatl
words but are common to Mexico and maybe
have special usage in Mexico in Mexico
when you want someone to repeat
something because you didn't catch what
they said you asked Monday this is also
used in chavacano I also hear that a lot
of chavacano swear words are of
specifically Mexican origin but I'll
skip those for now so are chavacano and
Spanish mutually intelligible well yes
and no some chavacano speakers have told
me that they can understand around 60%
or more of certain varieties of Spanish
in particular European Spanish and
Mexican Spanish but this is not
necessarily true for Spanish speakers
who hear chavacano while most chavacano
speakers are familiar with the word
order of English and maybe the word
order of Spanish itself Spanish speakers
are generally not familiar with the word
order of Filipino languages like Tagalog
or Visayan so when they hear chavacano
they might just hear a mishmash of
Spanish words but be confused by how
they're being put together in sentences
this is especially true for informal
chavacano which has more influence from
Filipino languages whereas formal
chavacano is closer to Spanish but
probably with some basic exposure to the
grammar they could improve their
comprehension of it quite quickly some
people argue that chavacano really isn't
that different from other Filipino
languages like Tagalog or Visayan which
contain a lot of Spanish vocabulary
themselves chavacano just has a lot more
of it the question of the day for
Spanish speakers how well can you
understand chavacano I'll leave a link
to a chavacano video in the description
for you to see before commenting if you
want and for chavacano speakers how well
can you understand spanish does it
depend on the variety of Spanish or on
the context be sure to follow Lange
focus on Facebook Twitter and Instagram
especially Instagram because it's the
coolest and once again I'd like to say
thank you to all of my patreon
supporters especially these ones right
here on the screen who are my top tier
patreon supporters many thanks to them
and to you thank you for watching and
have a nice day
[Music]
[Music]